What worries me is how we are all behaving in the face of this confrontation,
the confrontation that is taking place in the Palestinian territory of Gaza.
I am very concerned that we are trying to find justification for 1
failure and that we look for the D-Day of failure of all this madness
in 1 concrete action very by the way,
and very rejectable.
And I mean the never before.
Not to mention that since 1.
948, uh,
there is 1 state,
which is the State of Israel,
which has been passing through the triumphal arch all the resolutions
and recommendations of the United Nations,
thanks to its partner in the United Nations Security Council,
which is the United States,
to trample and crush eh,
all the rights and desires for freedom of 1 People like the Palestinian,
who have all the right in the world to be 1 state.
Therefore,
what worries me is that we abandon this perspective,
that we fall into this kind of media hysteria that great powers
want to get us into so that we do not see the obvious.
And the obvious thing is that Gaza,
Jordan,
have been trampled for decades by the boot of the Israeli state,
which, uh,
did not make USE of self-defense but of its capacity to attack to,
uh,
strengthen its positions against the decisions of the United Nations,
pointing out that there it had to give rise to the existence of 2 states,
the Palestinian and the Israeli,
and that both had to be able to to develop fully and with,
eh,
and with full independence to,
to govern its designs.
And that,
unfortunately,
has not happened.
And the international community has been looking the other way.
I would like this to change,
because I believe that the images that come to us day after day
of what is happening in Palestine challenge us all,
but not as,
not as people with one political meaning of one sign or another,
but as human beings.